digo herrera también conocido como yayo
usted está tomando parte en una campaña
que acaba de iniciar lanzada por el
trick el centro de recursos en
intercultural sobre la situación de los
inmigrantes aquí puede su participación
en la misma
me invitaron a participar como
ilustrador haciendo una serie de afiches
unos carteles que además van a ser
reproducidos en otros formal de tazas y
en otros medios el de la campaña
entonces me propusieron interpretar una
serie de dibujos y de textos que habían
hecho niños y adultos inmigrantes aquí
en montreal además
con la
con los conceptos de las ideas las
opiniones del equipo del clip entonces
tomamos todo eso lo resume en forma de
imágenes y así fue como cree las 22
cárter pets y como artista porque
considera usted importante participar en
una campaña en la que la situación de
los inmigrantes es el tema central
es un proyecto que
me toca de manera personal también
porque yo también soy el inmigrante como
ellos y las experiencias que estas
personas estos grandes cuentan con la
las emociones que se transmiten en sus
imágenes y en sus textos los comentarios
son experiencias que yo comparto que de
alguna manera u otra todos los
inmigrantes hemos tenido ese sentido
entonces de una parte
es una oportunidad para mí de devolver o
de estresar también
con mis herramientas como artistas con
mis manos con mi visión
puedo participar puedo dar algo y
también puedo expresarme y ser un poco
en cierta forma un portavoz con mis con
mis herramientas
yo aporto mi gran arena
a este evento
y ya que usted comparte con los
inmigrantes su situación uno de los
afiches dice que hay que remontar o
sobrellevar o vencer los límites los
problemas y los desafíos que se nos
puedan presentar como inmigrantes y
usted en su caso en particular pues son
las pendientes que tuvo que remontar a
como todos los muchos inmigrantes
primero hay un cambio geográfico
cultural entonces en este choque
los cambios vienen con cambio por
ejemplo de tener que aprender el idioma
o los idiomas y adaptarse y comprender
la manera de funcionar en la nueva el
país a donde llegas y en mi caso me tomo
más o menos un año en empezar a
a vivir de mi trabajo de un año para
aprender la lengua para desenvolverme
para defenderme y un año para aprender a
conocer un poco cómo funcionaban las
cosas aquí yo soy humorista gráfico e
ilustrador y estaba mi determinación era
vivir de eso
ser mi trabajo y de dónde vengo y donde
trabajado para diarios y revistas
entonces me tomo ese tiempo y conocer
otros colegas de aquí y aprender
a proponer mi trabajo como se hace aquí
en canadá una américa del norte entonces
frank periodo de inseguridad de
incertidumbre y de aprendizaje pues
varía la pena hacer el esfuerzo pero fue
un criado de angustia también de no
saber si iba a funcionar
sin embargo valía la pena y ya que estoy
hace 33 años y siempre trabajando con
mis imágenes y en este en este proyecto
en particular es muy significativo
porque dentro de los proyectos que he
hecho es la primera vez no una de las
primeras veces yo creo que la más
importante en la cual yo puedo
participar en una
de una manera muy concreta y muy
relacionada con el hecho de ser migrante
y de hacerlo con todos mis hermanos y
hermanas emigrantes de otros lugares
entonces
me siento muy
complacido pero más que eso emocionado
de poder participar y algún tiempo
aprecio muchísimo que el clic haya
pensado en mí para hacer lo que le guste
mi trabajo y me han dado la confianza y
carta blanca para hacerlo
y me dieron la información que tenían
pero aparte de eso tenía completamente
la libertad de hacer las imágenes que
quisiera y proponerse las
nos entendimos bien a partir de una
serie de bocetos que hice y los
discutimos también y
y ha resultado en estas imágenes que
estoy contento entre otras la imagen que
la que me hablas de la especie de pez
con alas muy significativo porque el más
es una especie bueno es un pez pero
puede ser una carpa y es conocida por su
perseverancia y poder contra la corte
bien
hasta superar obstáculos y eso yo creo
que es una de las cosas esenciales que
mismo los inmigrantes en todo el mundo
navidad pero ser muy grandes como
comenzado otra vida también entonces es
un ejemplo de símbolo de continuar
diego herrera ya yo hay unos pequeños
problemas en la línea así que por por
las dudas para no correr el riesgo de
paro de entrevista vamos a dejarla aquí
por el momento le agradezco esta
participación en radio canadá
internacional y quedamos en contacto
para un próximo encuentro para conocer
más profundamente su obra a lo largo de
estos 33 años aquí en el país gracias
muchísimas gracias por la invitación